don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
that's there were times I'm sure you
knew when I live in a more than I could
chew but through it all when there was
doubts
[Applause]
my way you really that was a missed
opportunity it should have been I did it
my hey babe well no no I thought about
this already yeah and did it hey babe
and I hey babe my way yeah that's what
it is yeah
good yeah all right I love this type of
music I love I listen to like Sinatra
you know Dean Martin Bobby Darin a lot
on the road oh yeah dude have you ever
heard the the Bobby Darin song chubby
Clementine no it's just about I just
found a new name for my penis
[Laughter]
is just about a fat girl who drowns
about it in a in a fun way where he's
like if I'm no swimmer but if she was
thinner no I would have saved chubby
Clementine oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] chunky
wait what does it say
um her crackle like thunder she went
under blowing bubbles down the line hey
I'm no swimmer but were she Slimmer I
might have saved that Clementine what
does it say go down it just me then he
goes hey you sailor way out in your
Whaler with a harpoon your trusty line
if she shows now you there she blows now
it just may be chunky Clementine oh my
God that's the nicest eulogy yeah she
blows now he's referring to her as a
whale you know you know where Dad's like
can you stop calling my daughter fat
she's dead all right she drowns listen
we just started here we just started of
course the hey bay podcast
um we have our beautiful guest Sam
Morrow one of the best comics in the
world and one thing we pride ourselves
on in this show Sam and what we do week
in week out anytime we have a guest is
we like to just we organic and we just
conversation flow you asked you have
anything prepared absolutely not with
just organic whatever goes so tell us
about that time uh you saw Julian Edmond
with no shirt on
I do a podcast games with names with
Julian Edelman from the Patriots and uh
only uh Super Bowl MVP ever who's a Jew
and I saw him shirtless and let me tell
you I should I should have did it I
should have did it where like football's
not our thing but there wasn't one
Jewish man on a roster in in simple MVP
oh okay no no no no it's only
professional sport well Sandy Koufax
probably wasn't MVP
who are the most valuable Jews
until some recent stuff came out uh no
he uh no he's a by the way I took my 23
in May and it came back like Lithuanian
check his Slovakian uh polish like any
country Hitler Steamroller yeah that's
me yeah just a weak Jew on it
just said wouldn't have made it out of
the Holocaust yeah but uh yeah
well this body this Holocaust bot next
to Julian Edelman who shredded like his
triceps one of those things I would tell
my daughter see there's two types of
Jewish people
well I told him when we did this I was
like this is like Inglorious Bastards
you're Brad Pitt I'm one of the weak
Jews basically yeah
fast
you know ugly actually he knows
everything
wow look at that photograph see okay
let's let's just stop hold the Press we
should be the same one of me just to put
it next to him
you should do it for your pod you should
recruit why does he have shoulder head
you have you have like a big patch of
psoriasis on your thigh
that's like that's like literally God
sculpted a human like what to have the
confidence to even entertain that right
as the cover to entertain the photo
shoot yes to talk to them they're gonna
You're Gonna Get You balls out and
You're Gonna Keep hopping in the air and
doing splits yeah and you know they'll
be they'll be lunch and then you know
there'll be 20 people photographing you
and you can do it to 100 times yeah how
about that Julian we're gonna cover ESPN
the only caveat is open [ __ ] what do
you think
like damn look at this first Jewish
football MVP of the Super Bowl and also
first ESPN Jewish person to show their
[ __ ] on the cover yeah amazing I I
mean dude it is but if you look I just
looked up most important juice
Harry Potter that's a big
hurricane I know that damn cute but but
but Natalie Portman I saw her on
Broadway as Anne Frank that's pretty
[ __ ] Jewish
what
[Laughter]
is not full Jewish because of the Adam
Sandler song Right Harrison Ford to
quarter Jewish not who shabby everyone
on Earth
is a quarter Jewish
is not a Jew
yeah it's not you
only uh if you were in the Adam Sandler
neither is O.J Simpson
um but I think as far as professional
athletes go Edelman I think as far as
like known Jewish athletes is probably
the top Jewish athlete him and Sandy
Koufax I can't think of Sean green was a
good baseball player Amari Stoudemire is
Jewish yeah you know that amarse he
converted converted you Judaism
[Laughter]
how'd you like the other versions of it
he started doing other versions
oh they're all great I mean he's the
best those are on my legitimate
Christmas playlists I listen to it every
year oh he there's certain songs I love
the South Park one too uh you know
Dreidel Dreidel Dreidel you know yeah
yeah but they do they do their own
version of it when Cartman comes in he
goes juice plays stupid games
that's why they're limit it makes me
laugh yeah Cartman is just you can't
beat Cartman as a as a villain did you
ever see no this is not great timing
actually but
do it
um there did you see the documentary the
aristocrats the records yeah right and
of course unfortunately the two names
that pop into my head when I think of
that are sagot and Gilbert yeah I know
yeah two of the best ones on there but
also they did a version I think it was
either in it or in the extras where the
Carmen tells the joke
did you ever say it no you could
probably pull it up right now it pull it
up it's not good timing I'll tell you
right you'll see in a moment
what is okay something about 911 yeah uh
well yeah hey we're all New Yorkers not
what not that we'll we'll you know play
this in the thing but
The Genius of the Joker that the
punchline is not funny everything else
is funny I mean Cartman ah God he's just
like South Park is one of those shows I
think we've talked about it before on
the show where there's so much above
everyone else comedy that they don't
even qualify for awards anymore yeah
like they never win an Emmy they're too
good they're just because it's like it's
like everyone else but the you know same
with the Curb Your Enthusiasm like
they're just the biggest [ __ ] like
they're just too good you know South
Park bigger longer and uncut the movie
from like it was probably 1999 or
something it's a top five comedy of all
time it also might be a top five musical
of all time yeah that's right it is
brilliant and it's ahead of its time
it's always going to be relevant because
people are always going to get offended
by stupid [ __ ] yeah and uh God it's like
the show itself it's like in The Book of
Mormons didn't they write Book of Mormon
is incredible Team America yeah
AIDS AIDS that's sex scene in Team
America oh my God it was insane they
made a movie with marionettes it's I
think my 12 year old stepson's too young
for that could I just bond with him I
think maybe no I don't know from what I
recall I don't think so I go 13 or 14.
12 year old you kind of watch that show
I remember let me tell you something
South Park came out in 1999 which means
I was 13 when it came out and my mom
wouldn't let me see it in theaters and I
resented the hell out of her for it
because then then it came out on DVD and
we watch it together and my mom was like
I was wrong this is really funny yeah
and you know what
I mean not a lot of kids get to watch
Uncle [ __ ] next to their mom but she
admitted it because you know what if
you're smart you realize
that that [ __ ] is like it's making fun
of people getting offended so you can't
get offended about it right it's genius
I actually loved it
they always their commentary on anything
that's happening that's controversial is
always the best take possible because
they [ __ ] on both sides that's what
entertainment's supposed to be you're
not supposed to only take one side you
real and they do it purpose perfectly
purposely this Bodega catch really good
try it dude I usually hate cats
but not this Bodega [ __ ]
it's nice it goes down nice it's really
smooth hey it's nice Bodega
catwhiskey.com folks there's not even
the bite is this it's so smooth I like
hey guys come see me on the road all
tickets are available right now at
savocano comedy.com uh my full dates are
up to the end of the year I'm gonna be
next week I'm gonna be in uh Hamilton
Ontario and Toronto Toronto we've added
a show that's October 14th and 15th and
the rest of October we're doing the
Richmond Virginia the carpenter theater
Hershey Pennsylvania they added a second
show there that's selling fast
um
and
that is all for October November we're
in Knoxville Atlanta and Birmingham
we're also in Louisville and Evansville
and then it rounds out in December I'm
going to Florida to Orlando Jacksonville
and Tampa and Tampa we added a second
show and I end the year over in
California I'm doing Santa Rosa
California San Jose California and we
are doing Sacramento everything's on
sale right now merch is up I got solo
merch and all the podcast merch is up as
well at salvolcanocounty.com hope to see
you guys on the road Thursday September
29th Milwaukee our Turner Ballroom that
show's almost sold out Friday September
30th Chicago Theater sold out baby
that's a big one and I'm throwing out
the first pitch at the Cubs game if you
want to come October 1st The Fillmore in
Minneapolis a couple of tickets left but
it's 95 sold out Galway Ireland October
12th we've just added at the trivia
theater okay and then Monday October
10th in Dublin we've added a second show
first show sold out of Liberty Hall we
added a second one got a couple of
tickets left every other show in London
and Belfast they're all sold out uh uh
so appreciate it appreciate all the
European support
um christycomedy.com for Ticky wikis and
we got merch baby we got new merch this
is the free opening game it still smells
like TT Jerry boofed it
um we got hoodies and sweatpants coming
out
um we got
a whole bunch of stuff every Tuesday
youtube.com christycomedy brand new hour
of stand-up material love it
Philadelphia is sold out everything is
is selling out so I appreciate it down
south in December get your Tiki wikis
New Year's Eve will be on sale soon
we're coming to Huntington Long Island
it's coming soon I am the new Long
Island Medium
[Laughter]
did you taste in order to arrive at like
nine
Norman and I did a taste test for it and
we didn't realize you're supposed to
spit out the whiskey while you're doing
the taste test so we were just
shit-faced are you gonna be serving this
at Norman's wedding I would like to be
yeah first time ever in New Orleans
Norman's wedding one of the best one of
the best cities what hotel should I stay
at I don't know let's make sure we all
stay at the same Hotel they gave a list
so oh did they yeah I know you know but
you ever need a hotel in any City king
of hotels why are you the king of hotels
he knows every he know he literally
almost off the top of his head can name
the top two three hotels in that City in
any City Road Warrior no one works
harder than Sal it's incredible like
shooting if you could find a hotel in
Toledo shooting Impractical Jokers he
does this he argues about Twizzlers with
DeRosa yeah
and then he [ __ ] does touring on top
of it at the end of this episode it's
like this episode's dedicated to sound
because he hung himself
after just praising him oh man dude
you're a machine no truth Impractical
Jokers will like save me sometimes on
flights or on the road I remember like
it's the thing to watch it is a it is a
really [ __ ] hilarious show thanks bro
thank you thank you I get you know yeah
I remember coming from you man no I mean
I [ __ ] love it it really is I it's
like when I'm on a flight and I need to
just laugh it's like I'm like I'm gonna
look for either Impractical Jokers or
like Rick and Morty or something I'm
like I want something to like that's
gonna be sick my go-to on flights is if
they have Jokers I watch because again
just past the time you just laugh you
don't have to like think about anything
or Good Fellas the movie Goodfellas I
like to pass the time and now recently
every time I'm on a flight for some
reason I watch two documentaries Anthony
Bourdain's the roadrunner and then did
you ever do you ever seen the Nolan
Express documentary about Nolan Ryan the
picture I heard it's great bro that's
[ __ ] guy Nolan Ryan
unbelievable I mean literally so
so when you're on every time you get on
a flight you look for the Nolan Ryan
documentary yes if we're flying Delta
yes
I'm looking just watching I'll stay off
the whole flight I'll say if I can you
can you reset my TV can you recess the
document is not on that reset is such
[ __ ] too they're like oh your
screen's not working let me reset it for
you yeah I'm sure this will work now the
reset doesn't work yeah it doesn't
really know what she does she goes or
hey they go up they go behind the thing
and they
can you just masturbate instead of
helping them yeah but the masturbation
reboots the system
um I'm not getting any Wi-Fi are you
sure because
you should be no it's something they'll
take you seven dollars for 30 minutes of
Wi-Fi can we invade a country Wi-Fi
shitty Wi-Fi free Wi-Fi Google is free
Yeah well yeah I think it's free yeah it
is shout out JB shout out JetBlue I love
JetBlue shout out the internet and
access to it at a reasonable price or
free yes shout out how about they do
that if free messaging if you have
T-Mobile no one has T-Mobile
he did he had it can I tell you a hack
he had a hack I had to beep this
no
[Laughter]
Tulane like I was a freshman and uh they
let me open for him and I still remember
uh it was like 500 Asian kids I was so
excited and I remember I I shook that
Fan's hand and he looked up he goes do
you have pink eye and I said yeah he
goes
you out there shaking hands bro that's
hilarious
hey your opener has pink eye is that it
okay
well I remember I remember I didn't know
it I was so dumb
freshman I didn't know what pink guy was
so I just I was like something's in my
eye so it's just went to the bathroom
sink pulled the water on high so it's
coming out as strong as ever it just
dumped my eye under it you like killing
in my eyes that might be reasonable it
just made it way worse yeah because yeah
you flushed it you let you do the show
with pink eye though yeah but he
wouldn't touch me and I I understand it
now yeah that's like Nick Kroll once I
met while I was at Montreal that's why
that's why I love Nick Kroll Nick Crow I
literally and again I was nervous
whatever this I was doing new faces
2013. I a guy who nickroll's manager or
age or maybe was publicist I didn't know
who this person was but I sneezed right
like I was like in the thing I was
saying hello to people whoever my
manager at the time people and I sneezed
and I was like yeah I was like so sorry
I was like you know and like a one and I
said and I went and then the uh AJ
manager goes I'm not touching goes why
would you put your hand out if you just
sneezed like really like talk down to me
and Nick crawl I swear to God he goes
give me that hand I don't give a [ __ ] a
full pound and like hugged me and was
like I you know like you got whatever he
said like he was like he was calling me
like Snot hand and I was like I like
this guy because he just I mean I was
like dude I literally you know you're
gonna get sick for about a week started
that's how I started it original he
missed a 20 million dollar movie role
for that joke yeah
we used to do the meet and greets after
the Joker shows when we do that tour too
and uh I would have them uh sanitized
before they stepped up good I had a
station a sanitizing station yeah I mean
that's the thing is like even people
actually was just covered I would do
meet and greet pre-covered and I would
get sick like every three weeks and I'd
be like yeah because I'm [ __ ] like
hugging strangers and they don't get it
either like oh come on you don't want
and I'm like no it's not like that it's
just that I can't shake hundreds of
people also some guy's a guy of HPV
nickels like give me that dick and you
suck that dick pox open up that [ __ ]
dude Nick girls meet and greet is crazy
dude speaking of uh fans surgeon
struggles to remove live snake from
women's ear and viral video I mean how
do you get a live snake in your ear like
how practice practice
a lot imagine I'm gonna lie I don't even
go to the doctor I just killed myself
100 right as it happens yeah as soon as
that snake gets in there I'm like
there's nothing left for me here on this
earth right that isn't that is that's a
legitimate snake in your ear
yeah
snake in your ears where does the snake
go I don't know where do you where do
you go my lovely how does that not kill
you you feel like the snakes just being
your head wouldn't kill you there's no
way
there's no way out of the do we have any
details did she put it in or was she
like sleeping camping I watched oh my
God oh my God oh my God literally she's
is she she has to be knocked out right
she's all fully awake she's awake bro
she don't want a practical joke she
didn't want to miss that she's watching
the Nolan Ryan documentary that's why
she's unfazed unfazed it won't open its
mouth
[Music]
look at her face it's grimacing a little
bit that allegedly is rough yeah yeah
that makes it sound like how about
but how did it get in here yeah and how
about the dirt people get gerbils in
their ass don't they yeah
allegedly allegedly well this is
allegedly too I think I was there though
I think I told you the story told the
story once on on hey babe I might have
when when I was a physical therapist and
the guy came in with back pain
what's up guys let's talk about mint
mobile after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
Wireless providers if we learned
anything it's that there's always a
catch so when we first heard about mint
mobile and that they offer premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month we were like what is the
catch but after speaking with them and
uh them giving us some samples and some
people using their service it makes
sense there isn't a catch mint Mobile's
Secret Sauce is after the first company
to sell wireless service online only so
by cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead costs uh that get passed
down to you in the form of mystery fees
instead mint just passes on sweet
savings directly to you
for people looking for extra savings on
their mobile plans mint mobile offers
premium Wireless for just 15 a month all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network you use your
phone with any mint Mobile plan and keep
your same phone number
um along with all your existing contacts
if you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven day
money back guarantee switch to Mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com hey
babe that's
mintmobile.com hey babe cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com hey babe
guys let's talk about ship station the
best time to prepare for growth is
before the opportunity arrives
especially with online businesses if you
have an online business where you're
shipping anything whether you're selling
things or you need to ship things ship
station check it out okay
um you want to get ready for especially
the holidays coming up to busy shipping
season uh ahead of time so it's it's
less stressful
um and basically ship all of your
products uh from one place which means
that it's just simplified it's
streamlined it's easier you're going to
get better rates shipstation sets you up
for growth by directly integrating with
every shopping cart and storefront so
your products are easy to find they're
easy to manage they're easier to get the
uh into the hands of your happy
customers uh don't wait until you're
drowning in orders to get something uh
to find the right uh you know the right
solution with shipping station uh
upgrade to ship station today whether
you're starting small or you're scaling
up ship station makes ship happen it's a
cute little pun no more limiting your
business to one store so they so what
ship station does it integrates with
every single platform so Amazon
Etsy eBay Shopify you can manage all of
your shipping from One dashboard in ship
station maximize the sales with minimal
effort
save time we Consolidated order
management and auto shipping for
customers get the same discount rates as
Fortune 500 companies whether you're
sending a stack of things or a truck
full of things so the rates are amazing
join over 130 000 companies who have
grown their e-commerce business with
ship station 98 of the companies that
use ship station for one year become
customers for life that's very telling
uh more and grow more with ship station
go to shipstation.com today and sign up
with the promo code hey babe for a free
60 day trial 6-0 start today and get set
up uh before the biggest shipping season
of the year the holiday season they get
two months free visit shipstation.com
Click the microphone at the top and type
in the code hey babe
this guy came in with back pain my first
year physical therapy school and I was a
you know I was a licensed physical
therapist but young and you know young
in the game so my boss would still come
in and chat on me and watch and
everything and this guy because he's a
guy excruciating lower back pain so
doing all the tests when part of
physical therapies you have to reproduce
the pain to know so he keeps reprodu you
should keep trying to reproduce the pain
and it's not happening and then even
then my boss gets in the bus I got you
know he's 30 years of experience he goes
let me see so then he's going you know
doing the massage whatever and he goes
sir I don't I have no idea where this is
coming from because there have been
injury that we don't know about whatever
he goes no nothing out of the ordinary
goes all right would you want to take a
get an MRI or an x-ray goes no I really
don't want you because that's the only
way we can really alleviate this pain
and he goes now I'm not going to do it
and then he steps off the thing and he's
like in excruciating pain the guy's like
you need to let us get an MRI like you
have to let us give you an MRI and so
the office the MRI office was right next
to the physical therapy office so
we leave you know we take him into the
MRI goes against the MRI and he's still
in there and the MRI Tech and Doctor Who
were all you know friendly with because
work there they go guys get in here
tell us to go guys get in here bro they
put the MRI up the X-ray up he had uh
what was it Matchbox cars
um some other item a host of things a
host of no it was Matchbox items it was
it was like they're like it's not just a
toy car it's Matchbox it's a good ad for
the company yeah Matchbox cars I don't
know about you guys
Hot Wheels don't even try it Hot Wheels
yeah the wheels are too big they're hot
he had put Match and something else in a
condom and lubed them up his ass for
like sexual pleasure I think he was like
undercover gay but this guy had like
wife kids like a soccer dad like you
would never think and he had a full
match and then you know we the the the
doc you know it comes to the doctor and
the doctor was like you know is there
you know we see some items foreign items
in your anal cavity
um I don't know dude I think Matchbox is
made right here in the U.S
foreign
that's not the pain I'm feeling though
that has nothing to do with it the
doctor's like no you have a foreign item
in your anal cavity that is what is
causing the pain we need to surgically
remove it he's like that's not it it's
something I parked out there monthly
yeah yeah I did a bunch of squats
yesterday that's what my glutes are sore
it's not the it's not the item in my ass
yeah no that's gotta be more that's one
thing you know did they remove it I as
far as we know how do you walk around
with that [ __ ] in you
do one of Trump's lawyers one I forgot I
actually I forgot his name even if I
remember his name I I would say it I
don't give a [ __ ] because I don't even
have a license anymore but um but one of
Trump's attorney this was again 2010 so
before Trump was anything present or
anything like that he came in and he had
um you know all this like groin pain
whatever same thing can't reproduce and
then finally he says to me and my boss
he goes I like you know I I have like a
huge like rash down here thing whatever
he had like full gonorrhea like rampant
like rampant full God like STD dick
swollen like disgusting [ __ ] and so the
doctor you know my therapy boss was like
you know you're gonna have to like get a
script like we're gonna like we can't do
anything for you until I can clear up
that infection he goes look man like you
know I got a wife like she checks
everything like my insurance like she
sees everything like I can't get this
medicine under my name and they're like
you you have to get it it's your
medicine to you and he goes um to me he
goes you know how old are you and I was
like 25 26 he goes I'll give you like 10
grand if I we can put it in your name he
goes you don't have a wife or kids you
have to sign me up I swear to God he
goes I'll give you 10 grand and I was
gonna say yes and then my boss was like
get the [ __ ] out of my office he's like
you're not gonna brought this kid could
lose his license for that over 10 grand
and and then like it threw him out and I
I remember like to my boss being like I
would have gladly done that I'm I'm
paying five dollars to get on stage with
the Maui taco night after night like I
could have used the money button it's
like I remember I'll name him isn't it
like HIPAA isn't there all sorts of hip
belongs yeah but I don't have a license
anymore so I feel like what you know
like what am I going to do you're
telling the story like I really regret
not taking that money yeah I know I
would have but it makes sense but it's
like that like when you work in the
medical field you see all like every day
you see [ __ ] crazy just in me as a
physical therapist I saw crazy [ __ ] like
I can imagine what it's like to be like
an ER doctor like they see things daily
that like you would your life would
change if you saw it and to them it's
just like a regular Tuesday yeah no
wonder they're numb and they're just
like they're shut down because they have
to they have to keep feelings over here
I mean every doctor is like every place
my uncle was like a doctor house type
doctor in uh in Maryland talk to a house
he's like that type of dog he's like
he's breaking the rules he's always
fighting the system oh he's a bad boy
he's like the bad boy of his he was
given Ivermectin day one
he is that dude where he's just like you
know always risking getting fired but I
[ __ ] love doctors like that yeah that
just bent they play a little bit like
you go to the doctor
you have a situation like that I don't
know maybe you had some drinks maybe you
were with someone who wanted to
experiment maybe you just can't trust
your judgment right but you end up
putting some birth control up your ass
birth control you end up putting
something up your ass yeah yeah you have
to go to the doctor no choice do you
just say that I'm just gonna lead with
it or you're going to do the dance that
they these people did are you going to
walk the lead with it it's a doctor
listen can we close the door and look I
don't you know what I don't like when
you go to the doctor when like other
people are hovering oh doing they're
like oh we have a student in here like
let me see a picture of her yeah I'm
gonna take my dick I don't want to see
what she looks like yeah it's like oh
they're just shattering us I'm like and
who are they where are their credentials
yeah you know like I don't know but I I
would you go with a student about a
friend I got a yeah dude just this guy's
a Peeping Tom we got a few people in
here yeah yeah this is uh someone who's
training that girl is like bro
my roommate is looking into town yeah I
think I think I'd open with it I think
I'd say I have you know let's be frank
right away let's be frank I I like to
play with items my children have a lot
of Matchbox cars in the house I stick
them up my ass periodically things are a
little tense with the wife at home sure
and this makes me feel better but now I
think I push too far literally where I'm
having excruciating back pain so just
handle it you would do that I think I
think I think it's best to just be
honest with the doctors and just be like
this is what it is like I remember once
I came into this I forgot what summer it
was I I came in twice in one summer with
chlamydia and the doctor was just like
listen this is chlamydia summer summer
twice twice you doubled up I doubled up
and was it no immunity from the first
one I don't know what the hell happened
and he says to me listen just he goes
you're one of the only patients I have
like this but I'm going to give you a
preventative medication he goes I'm just
gonna give you the antibiotics I'm just
going to give you a 14 day supply so if
you start to feel that that pain and and
uh burning and urine again just take the
pills for seven days I'll give you two
rounds of it I was like thank you sir
but I've learned my lesson I got
chlamydia three weeks later three times
yeah three times in one summer that was
you know how was that you know what they
call it are you just raw dogging yeah
that is almost impossible you know what
they call three claps in one summer and
Applause
this guy this guy
so I can't come to work he's on an
Applause break
you got three claps three claps but no
but there's only three times I got it
all right
I think Chris is acting like he's a
born-again Christian yeah just because
he didn't get chlamydia again
three times in one summer yeah
just really hurt myself yeah it might
have been three different sources I
don't know you got more sources than an
Atlantic article
we do it for two yeah but I I just don't
get um like is is it is is the clap that
easy to get nowadays
it was in the summer of 2016.
2018. would you be do you think if you
were a single man you'd be getting
monkey pox like like it's I think I was
thinking about this
pimp is nodding I was thinking about
this I was actually thinking about this
the other day I think if I was single
right now I wouldn't just because it's
so I've realized I've lived both lives
now to live to wake up every day and
just know it is an impossibility to have
an STD just brings my anxiety almost
down to zero like my pee was burning the
other day when I was in San Fran and I
was like there's no it's impossible it's
an STD it might be prostate cancer but
at least it's not chlamydia again
because there's such like a negative
stereotype on STD by the way my P is
burning NSF one of my favorite Tony
Bennett songs
[Laughter]
about the fat girl drowns
I'm no swimmer but where she's Savannah
I might have saved Shelby Clementine oh
Bobby Garrett seems like Bobby Darin's a
guy it would probably be fun he died
young as [ __ ] did he 37. wow some weird
freak death I don't look it up he was uh
Bobby Darin [ __ ] ruled you know it
those Tunes yeah yeah uh beyond the
scene oh my God the best Bobby Darin
died at the age of 37 heart ailments wow
well the funniest part is Kevin Spacey
was obsessed with him and really wanted
to play him but he couldn't get the
funding I guess till he was like in his
late 40s so he's he looks old as [ __ ]
pull up a picture of Kevin Spacey
playing a guy who died at 37. this is
Kevin Spacey's young Bobby dad and look
he crushes the saying because Kevin
Spacey can [ __ ] oh yeah he can right
yeah
I mean yeah yeah he looks way older he
looks old as [ __ ] for a guy who died at
37.
it's like Robert De Niro and the
Irishman
he's so good though
it's it's jarring this dude is not
33 or whatever he's playing yeah right
right is it what were people way cooler
back then they were right I think they
carry themselves they weren't pimp says
no well I think that back then there
were rules I mean life like you have to
it's not not less the progressiveness I
know that but like people just carried
themselves
cooler I think people cared more about
you know the way a building looked like
all those designs like those Art Deco
designed so much attention to detail
they would come out in suits girls would
come out and dresses now it's like you
know we don't know
50 minimum here look at this yeah this
is ridiculous look at him this guy is
not early 30s he looks like Ryan Reese
well Ryan Reese that was a good one that
was a very good one now welcome to the
stage Krista stefana
um no there was something I mean look
they were they were cooler in the sense
that they kept their [ __ ] in here they
weren't like on Tick Tock crying like
I'm sad and getting a shitload of videos
binocular and like the way they like the
way they spoke so yeah
if you gave them socials they're a
nightmare yeah oh my God if Bobby
Darin's writing my songs in public about
fat women drowning imagine him drunk at
night with a Twitter yeah what would it
be like if they have social media
social media back then that's the stuff
he's putting out in public he's like
this is okay he's just [ __ ] facing the
computer I'm glad Chevy Clementine's
dead yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] he's like he's a
part of the song I didn't I didn't
include chubby Clementine sucks a good
dick
that's actually really drowned
smash that subscribe button
hello fresh is working with 65 off plus
free shipping right now what is
hellofresh if you're a new listener
hello fresh is America's number one meal
kit and with hellofresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
seasonal recipes delivered right to your
doorstep uh skip trips to the grocery
store you count on hellofresh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable
that's why they're America's number one
meal kit now more than ever oh they're
looking at ways to save you money in
fact hellofresh is 25 less expensive
than takeout it's even cheaper than uh
shopping at the grocery store
um selections of over 30 recipes uh 20
minute meals 30 minute meals uh look if
you're getting home from work you don't
have the time quick and easy meals low
prep easy cleaner cleanup options take
the stress out of the meal okay full is
the perfect time to Cozy up with some of
that delicious sweets get the whole
family involved in hellofresh's limited
edition kid-friendly baking kits that's
cool I get Hella fresh delivered I
didn't know that I'm gonna check that
and do that with my nieces um you could
easily customize your meals with hello
custom you could swap in proteins or
sides upgrade it's never been easier
dude saves me time saves me money uh it
encourages me to cook which I normally
don't do go to hellofresh.com hey babe65
the number six and five and use code
heybade65 for 65 off plus free shipping
again go to hellofresh.com hey babe six
five and use the code hey babe six five
for up to 65 no 465 off plus free
shipping hello fresh Mark's number one
meal okay
um dude I've done a doing a little
experiment I don't have I have social
media I post up but I don't have the
keys to it I have no way to yes someone
wrote me back on your behalf the other
day when I met yeah yeah
it is as a matter of fact the guy who
put me in touch with because I was
Shadow banned that's this is interesting
the first week I gave my Instagram to
somebody else we were Shadow band
um but but but that guy who he put me in
touch with who works at Danny ID Jenny
Danny great guy great he was saying he
was like because I was telling him I was
like dude I was like it's um I don't run
it anymore he goes That's so healthy he
was like that's so mentally healthy I
got guys to not see it all the time I
think I gotta get off and the only way I
can get off is with Matchbox cars yeah
I I think internally they know social
media companies know that it's just like
how the cigarette companies just knew it
was ruining our uh lung Health but they
were like we got them oh they have all
the studies I mean Facebook and
Instagram they have the studies that
show this is like damaging young women's
self-esteems the filters the fake things
and they're just like yeah we know yeah
they're not changing it but they do the
study so they know well I think in a way
it kind of makes it your brain go back
to a little old school where like you
kind of only know what's happening in
the world around you which is what our
brains are designed to do for like
safety and all that it's like our brains
aren't designed to know what's going on
across the world that yeah we shouldn't
care about I know what's going on in the
Ukraine but I know what's going on on
Chrissy chaos exactly that's all that
matters to me baby yeah but without the
social media how are the girls supposed
to know how they should look exactly
it's a good point
it's a good boy good boy I was waiting
at Brady and Gisele
that was about to break up well that's
great because I drafted him and he got
me 12 points last night
Dax Prescott's going to be like out for
the half the season
it's crazy good [ __ ] the Cowboys they
think TJ watt tore his pectoral Naji
Harris already has a foot injury my
first two picks were saquan and Josh
Allen I'm [ __ ] Riding High right now
baby
I think I was like 11th or something my
draft I love uh
I told Sam I was on the flight the
Giants came and you know on on Sunday
they they beat the Titans by one miss
field goal the guy sitting next to me
big Giants fan got so excited he like
added happiness punched his headrest
from the TV and the lady in front of him
when he threw her was she was mid-sip
but she went like that and Spilled wine
all over the kids sitting in front of
him it looks like a chain reaction it
was a whole thing
yeah what is this what type of training
is this
not real
that can't be real it's that's the stun
right she's getting pulled back at the
exact time and he's faking hitting her
oh
my God
you're in dangling
it actually looks fun like everyone
there is okay with this
imagine it was real yeah not only are
they came with it zero reaction
wow everything looks [ __ ] that's
amazing I mean you want even pro
wrestling you watch sometimes you're
like it's not even coming close to
hitting the guy
genuinely real oh that looks real it's
like an Isis guy standing at the edge of
Afghanistan
how do oh what is this now
why women are trying to run for their
freedom
um
sorry this has been hey babe
what is this is real wow
it's funny it takes you see we go we go
to such a length for happiness and then
you see how happy they get from just
this [ __ ] yeah look they don't care if
they sold out an improv
they can't believe that they they can't
believe they made it to 30.
those guys are definitely from I feel
like that that that is a very like like
soccer hooligan Vibe for sure this is in
Europe No Doubt yeah you can tell by the
haircuts for sure
um Sam what um oh wait what's this
did what
oh that's not her boyfriend
wait what oh that's the boyfriend next
to her does she know
yeah it's her fault now why are you
pouring on him that's her fault he
doesn't know
that can't be real
that might be people fight so I think
this is the West Indian Day Parade but
who's following only them with their
camera and that can't be real oh he and
he looked at the camera too it's not
real
that's pretty great the West ending Day
Parade it was so funny I saw on the news
the other night you know Western Day
Parade in New York they go oh they go um
you know Western Day Parade went off um
uh you know uh today um they would say
for the first time in five years no one
was shot they said uh first time
Fighters no one was shot and then like I
swear they like waited a pause they were
like there were two stabbings though
they said that they were like but there
were unfortunately two stabbings both
both victims uh in uh stable condition
is that a cop dancing with that's
probably real
so that guy oh wow
it's funny how you like you watch a TV
show and every cop's like I'm not gonna
sleep till I find this murder and in
real life they're just like dry humping
and chicks and parades that's a great
line in uh in Naked Gun yeah I promise
you no one on the no one on the force
will will sleep one will stop or sleep
one second until we find out who killed
your husband I love that now let's go
get a bite
wait this cop this cop dancing with this
girl he's definitely going to be written
up on disciplinary actions for that you
can't do that right even though it's fun
well that was the serve of protect and
serve that was protected I know he's
like she's she's like grinding on him
he's like well black lives matter
hello cops cannot catch a break right
it's either
it's one or the other yeah wow guy's got
a good haircut I wonder where he goes
Thai fade that is a tight fade look at
the fa that guy's receding hairline a
bit but the back the side it looks good
looks like a soccer hooligan this guy he
does yeah he wants to use his head to
hit a fight that's bolts is he getting
in trouble
I'm sure oh yeah of course well is it
somewhere in the bylaws that you can't
dance well some some NYPD officer at the
Christmas party last year was giving the
sergeant a lap dance and she got in a
lot of trouble yeah she did it again
like two months ago no I didn't know
that yeah he gave he gave the sergeant a
lap dance she gave to Sergeant a lap
dance and she got like in a lot of
trouble so it's like he doesn't get in
trouble he was married yeah right and
all that stuff it was like a big thing
there you go this is at the parade too
yeah this is at the parade wow it's the
two stabbings were happening
here going off on his way
s
they come in right now
I'm doing my own stamps he's like sorry
I'm being assaulted
calls in for backup we're in a 10-year
honeymoon living off eight dollars a day
by selling nudes well that's not that
should tell you that your body's not the
best
honeymoon no
what do I say it's also telling you
you're not going on a great honeymoon if
it's eight dollars a day Jesus Christ
yeah a [ __ ] days in and [ __ ]
Austin is like 130 a night I and I know
where the hell are you going when you
scroll down to the bottom of this
article you'd be like you can check out
their podcast on Apple
yeah they'll be performing live at the
[ __ ] look at them look how limber
they are I like that they probably have
good sex what are they doing they're
selling nudes and to supplement their
lifestyle they probably stink though
yeah they might tell you that look at
that little smelly
is that a full sex shot
they were actively having sex oh sorry
who's taking these who's got that who's
got a thumb ring like that I almost see
your thumb ring in every photo enough
enough with the thumb ring
nice I kind of why do people care why do
people care about this
who cares
it would never occur to me this is
annoying that every picture is him like
either making out with her like like
touching his face like this just [ __ ]
it bothers me when couples like your
whole identity is wrapped up in your
couple yeah like have a little bit of a
personal identity post one pic of just
you does every photo have to be you dry
humping your [ __ ] wife a new 800
horseshit [ __ ] honeymoon
this doesn't look like eight bucks a day
yeah kidding me where are they how much
was that cross on right there
yeah where the [ __ ] are you staying
eight dollars a day
these people are the real terrorists
God they suck
um did you see did you uh I mean I'll
bring that up together what no that's
not it's gonna go nowhere no it's it's
again not the right time
did you see what happened to the towers
nothing to do with that
I was walking downtown
so um what is this a man uh this is from
baller alert a man was caught on
surveillance cameras following a mother
and daughter around sniffing the teens
behind oh that's good no that's very hey
babe oh my God damn
oh my god
wow damn sniffing a team yeah that's not
good what is wrong with people what
percentage of the population would you
say has at least a little something
wrong with them I love young Miami 305's
coming I really wish he just farted
[Laughter]
I guess the knighting is good yeah but
you might be on both knees for the
nighting right I don't know maybe that's
the whole Community you're getting
ignited that's true I mean if you're
that guy right you have you're either
that guy's either crazy or he has such a
problem with a fetish that he can't even
like he's that person is not well
adjusted you can't do that no it's I
disagree I think he's pretty cool
no I mean like you think he's completely
off the office rocker completely like
the guy sniffing it sniffing ass yeah I
think that that's more than like a
fetish that's someone who's like in like
truly insane yeah just get a job as like
a sommelier or something if you have a
really good you know smelling game like
what are you doing what was he in like a
Walgreens right there yeah you can't
help yourself in a [ __ ] Dwayne read
you got a problem my friend
yo just just get some kind of job or
like you know like you clean buses or
train something that you can just sniff
the seats when the people get up you
know what I mean like when they when the
train Chris is a more lenient rehab idea
than I do yeah Sarah Silverman had a
tweet one time and I still remember this
that is really funny she said the
richest guy in New York City has to be
the richest black man in New York City
has to be Dwayne Reed
Dwayne Reed you know why it's called
Dwayne Reed because it started on Dwayne
and Reed Street right you're absolutely
correct wow New York facts Chrissy d
I think that's just a New York store is
it no I think so really CVS and
Walgreens are the National ones I think
Duane Reade is just New York no wonder
why when I asked what's going to read
somewhere else they look at me like
crazy you know what I always wanted to
do
be on Hollywood Squares really yeah it
does look fun it looks fine you should
bring that back I know because there's
so many weird type of famous people now
that you can get a real eclectic Bunch
on those squares maybe I'll be sure to
revive that I wonder who owns that IP
probably Howie Mandel yeah he's probably
the guy that owns it I mean no rules
that guy's like he's a good guy you guys
are tight right yeah well yeah we're
talking we're going to do something
together but then it fell through but he
was so like he's just the man I sold the
show with him once really we made a
pilot and it didn't go anywhere though I
believe was in it actually the great
Bobby Lee who's Owen Benjamin who sat on
this couch Bobby Lee sat on this couch
last week it was hilarious that's when
Ellen Benjamin turned to that that's his
super villain origin story yeah what
about uh
uh Howie Mandel he was so nice I did
America's Got Talent back in the day he
was sorry oh [ __ ] that's right they I
got a limit I lost to a mine but he was
a [ __ ] good Mom no no bad blood there
that guy tape face that guy's a [ __ ]
beast
he won one didn't he win win I don't
know but he's in Vegas is his own
residency if you get a residency in
Vegas that's like I mean that's big
money right tape face is making he he's
probably do you think tape face now what
the money has is gone has upgraded his
tape you think he's got like it's not
Scotch anymore it's duck it's done doc a
ducked
I think it's ducked I thought it was
it'd be a good Batman he's got the tape
on the face he kidnapped school by
putting tape on their face he's the
whole you know that one said duct tape
up top is it duck or duct tape
Ducks also called duck from the cotton
duck cloth that was originally made of
wow he's a phenomenal performer that guy
he's a great put on a great yeah I don't
know you don't think so no I mean I
don't know him I just feel like I just
don't know if I saw that if I'd be like
I want to watch this well I don't know
either because I only watched it there
but put off a clip pull up a clip of
tape face speaking of faces um who was
what's his name Kevin Smith yes skinny
mini oh yeah man he looks great I like
Kevin Smith I grew up on those movies
like I love clerks and Mall Rats and
Chasing Amy and all that yeah
the clerks three comes out tomorrow I
have like two lines in it do you really
yeah way to bury the lead that's [ __ ]
great uh yeah just yeah I mean it's I
mean literally it's probably oh that
comes out well I've known him for a
really long time uh because Q Ryan Quinn
uh used to work for him and know him
like 20 years ago so we met like 20
years ago oh wow yeah like uh yeah so
he's been I've been housed with him for
a long time I think this is the actually
this segment that knocked me out how is
he Howie Mandel allowing him to touch
him
can I tell you something he just whipped
his dick
Jesus Christ
I I was on I went to how he invited me
to come watch us at Radio City so I went
and then one time and I was backstage
with him we were talking and I went to
say goodbye and Howie actually shook my
hands wow he didn't realize it and I
went to and we did it and I went oh
right in the middle of it and he was
like I don't know so this is not all the
time well no well you and Howie I think
because you and Howie Mandel are the
guys both know like germs do not like
you're like the unstoppable train versus
the immovable objects either he knew
Sal's hands were the cleanest man I
don't know
not that that makes it I don't I mean
anyway because I just prefer the fist
bump but I also I kiss on the lips yeah
and every meet and greet guy girl what
do you think I can't wait for a goodbye
after the show
which would you take on families uh the
kiss on the lips
kids each other whatever any version of
I think it's weird as [ __ ] yes I don't
pass a certain age or like I kiss I kiss
you baby well let me let me let me put
it out to your lips I still your baby I
I'm not I'm not okay with your little
baby
elephant I remember there was like one
year old on the lips I remember seeing
the kid get dropped off at school and we
were probably like five or six and his
mom goes on his mouth and I was like I
mean I want to bang your mom but that's
[ __ ] weird yeah yeah like that's it's
it's like I don't know I kissed
well that Embrace is weird
oh Tom Brady just Tom Brady kids like
too many people that's funny that that
picture down there
who's the old man
it's his dad
um Edelman I I never kissed you on the
lips funny I would kill for I would you
know what I would like to get kissed on
the list by Tom Brady me too I think
parents and younger kids is out of line
I don't think I think I I think
I kiss my baby on the lips Christ I mean
that's ridiculous whoa that's that's got
to be photoshopped that's photoshopped
that's got to be photoshopped that's
they're they're literally locked
he's smushing his face
that can't be real I heard I heard Tom
Brady makes out with his son to Chubby
Clementine the song have you heard that
it's crazy that's weird yeah I'm gonna
kiss my dog I kiss my older daughter on
the lips sometimes it depends usually
it's on the cheek I just give her a hug
review you were like no no no no no no
not at all not in your family at all
Oh no just on the like when you were a
baby
[Laughter]
does the video get paused or is he there
that long
why that looked like it was the
beginning of CPR then he sucks his
nipple
then he tea bags them
this is this video they're they're
actually talking about the kiss in the
video is that why this is a video to
begin with
it's funny that he's shirtless of being
massaged when it happens like that it
doesn't it doesn't help the agency it
doesn't help
at the time yeah also it's weird this is
why I came back to the NFL just I was
like you never kiss him on the mouth
anymore
[Laughter]
hi Sean I love that he's showing it to
three black guys they're like these he's
like that's why people [ __ ]
he goes it's two those two black guys in
De Niro look at that guy was part of the
Kremlin I think you know but it's not in
the mouth but not for that long too long
too long like romantic long
yeah I kissed myself in my lips I have
since day one you know I would have no
problem with myself with me like that
lifestyle and parenting expert list
Stern says she doesn't see anything
wrong if you kiss your kids too much
it's the wrong thing if you kiss your
kid
you're like I'll suck my son's dick
I I know I could see it I could see it
with kids I think it's like when they're
babies you just like are so enthralled
by them that you just want to eat them
you get that but I think um it can I
love eating babies but I will say though
I will say you don't you want to make
sure that your kids know not to just
kiss people on the lips like you know
even people that visit the house oh
hello and then they go to kiss them on
the lips you know I I worked with
someone uh one time that used to kiss on
the lips that's [ __ ] weird and it was
shocking what do you mean they would
kiss you when they came in to work on
the lips everybody
what nationality was it like a European
thing or something no they were full at
Staten Island white I don't know there's
that nylon white but
some people will just kiss you on the
mouth and you're like oh like off the
right we were like all right yeah there
was a European level of comfort there or
something like even when I kid something
to kiss a family around the cheek I
really just go cheek to cheek I don't
put my lips on their cheek yeah like you
know what I mean like I'll just be like
like I'll make a kissing sound go so you
just tucked cheeks yeah I'm kissing into
the air making the sound I'm just gonna
make my lips speaking of cheeks Julian
Edelman the bad guy is his cheeks
um I I do give I actually will kiss the
face of the person yeah I just don't
know kisses I'm talking about like my
family you know like yeah no so I think
what my my I kiss you know I think my
seven-year-old sees us kiss the baby so
much on the lips on the head everywhere
that she's like wants to always be
kissed on the lips or kissed on the
cheek I think that's what it is but I'm
trying to think yeah I think like my 12
year old the stepson his mom doesn't
kiss him on the doesn't even I think she
kisses him on the head oh my gosh thank
God that never happened to me I think
that would have [ __ ] me up if my mom
kissed me on the mouth I'm already
dating women that are like my mom you
don't want to [ __ ] let's not take it
to that one like you said you know
you're open about like you grew up like
your dad was in the picture and the
first time you met him he kissed you
right on the lips he's like I haven't
seen you in 10 years come here Sammy
I kiss him in the mouth like [ __ ] and
Godfather too yeah you broke my heart
um yeah dude I [ __ ] he lives like seven
blocks of me it's so weird that's a
that's a wild thing isn't that weird and
he's always lived seven blocks I used to
do a bit of bad health first time I met
him he's petting a cat and I and I went
up to him and uh I was like what's up
with the categories I rescued her from
the side of the road and I nursed her
back to health and I was like so you did
have it in you
walks away
he's very close it's very even the cat
was cute as hell I'll give the cat there
it's a good cat he's like named him Sam
laughs
I was like man I was right there uh no I
have a half brother I've never met you
somewhere in California I've never met
him but uh I remember I floated the idea
to him once I was like I'd love to meet
him if he's interested and he goes yeah
I ran up by him and uh he didn't see him
into it I was like all right never mind
sorry yeah I mean well that you know my
mom had a you know her her family she
she had she had a a second family as
well like a father had another family
and she there was an opportunity to meet
uh uh one of her like half brothers that
she didn't know and she was like I just
don't I have no I do not want to mean he
reached out to me because he was a
musician and he was like hey can I open
for you I'm kind of like your half uncle
and I was like what I was like yeah
that's gonna explain the whole story and
then I brought it up to them and she was
like no don't want to meet them very
easy for me to say no I don't want to
deal with it I was like all right cool
and then I recently went back to like
look at those messages to like try again
I was thinking maybe it'd be a good
podcast guess he died of covet wow wow
damn that's it and I was like yeah Mom
you know that's uh you didn't get
I don't know there's no joke that is
[ __ ] crazy yeah I mean she's yeah
it's uh I I guess for me I was an only
child so I don't know for me I would
think like if I found out I had a
brother or sister I would want I'd do
anything to meet them well I want to
meet him but I have a stepbrother and
stepsister who are like actually I just
called him brother or sister right
because like you know we're we're good
so it's not like that but uh you know
and I have a dad who I lucked out my
dad's great so it's it's if anything I
feel really fortunate but there's always
that resentment where you're like oh
you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah but I'm not
but I'm also like thank God it happened
because if he was my dad I'd be worse
off for sure yeah you think you would do
comedy if you think you think like the
trajectory of your life changed because
of that I don't know I think I just am a
comedian I think it's just in me to be a
comedian so I don't think it's like one
thing makes you a comedian or not but I
do think uh
some people will be like well that
[ __ ] need to please maybe come from
that but I don't know I think I'd always
be okay my dad was it was it called
estranged I guess from his real dad too
wow and like of infant stage I got like
a couple of years old or whatever as a
toddler no no I was a piece of [ __ ] real
piece of [ __ ] really I know you're such
a good dad you're gonna be such a good
dad so it's like it's I can't picture
everyone I know I'm just like I can't
picture them not being a great dad so
imagine if you just knew someone who was
like yeah I don't talk to my kid I'd be
like that's [ __ ] crazy that's crazy
to me there's like never and even if the
mother of your kids is giving you like a
hard time calling you piece of [ __ ] it's
like will you still show up every week
to see your kids that's your job
I found out his biological dad was Bobby
Darin
that's why he used to call me clementine
um yeah but my dad's my dad's
I guess step dad who's really like his
real dad and oh we I ever knew uh
married my grandmother when they was
when my dad was like two or three and
then raised him so uh he's my he was
like you know I never even discerned not
from my real grandfather from him yeah
blood is overrated in those scenarios
too where you're like whoever provides
you whoever is there for you is your
parent I mean that certain places I
remember like when we had that issue
with Cuba a while back it was like you
can only go back if you're a blood
parent was like well what is a what is a
parent you know what I mean blood
doesn't mean you're a parent sometimes
the person that raises you is not
related to you right yeah like maybe
take it up a Bloom Cafe man take it up a
Bloom Cafe yeah like yeah
it's an inside it's something we say
yeah
there's a cafe a vegan cafe on Staten
Island and we've said take it up like we
said any issue you have in life take it
up with Bloom Cafe and they're getting
flooded with Yelp reviews and people are
going to their store being like I'm here
to take it up with you but do they are
they yeah but we told them the only way
you have to leave a positive comment
about their food or go in and eat their
food and then you continue they must
love you guys yeah I think it's hit and
miss oh really
and I did a similar thing on our podcast
to Charlie Sheen well we just were like
people were like who's your dream guest
and we might be drunk and we're like I
don't know why we both just said Charlie
Sheen because we're like we just feel
like that guy's like got amazing
drinking stories he's got a new thing
coming out with uh Doug Ellen who made
Entourage it looks good I mean yeah but
uh Charlie Sheen was [ __ ] great and
we're just like I feel like he'd be fun
Simon Rex who's a buddy of ours who's
you know who's done our pod or like is
friends with Charlie Sheen and he's like
I'm trying to get sheen on the Pod and
we're like we just want [ __ ] Sheen
bro just give us Charlie Sheen on the
Pod would break the end because he never
does anybody that's why we want him
because he never does pods he's done
Simon Rex's pod that's like the only
part he's done so Simon's pushing to get
him on our pod and uh I feel like his
HIV story didn't stick like everyone
thinks Magic Johnson HIV Charlie Sheen
you don't even think about that with him
yeah like you don't even think I forgot
I forgot did he have HIV we're like
magic Johnson it's constantly remind
like you always think well he got at the
time where it's insane that he didn't
die that's true right and when she and
got it you're like whatever yeah you're
like fine okay great when magic got it
he he was so he's such a pro athlete
badass that he was like I'm gonna beat
this and everyone's like you're not
you're gonna die and he was like no I'm
gonna beat this and he [ __ ] beat it
he beat it like it was bird on the
[ __ ] Celtics yeah just beat that
white [ __ ] age
you want to go out with uh one or two of
the best comments right now on the Yelp
yeah yeah let's let's see let's see the
Bloom Cafe comments on Yelp
um we've told you guys to do this we're
going to mention it every week go to the
Bloom Cafe Yelp leave rate the food give
it five stars say how much you love one
food item and then take take up an issue
any issue any issue you have so here we
go this is from Jake from Deer Park
Illinois uh he says the muffets here are
absolutely amazing definitely the place
you should stop into if you're looking
for any kind of cafe or something to get
work done pick up a snack or a coffee
fantastic place with that being said
recently I'd be getting more and more
frustrated with my neighbor's cat the
thing is always climbing over to my side
of the fence and making my dogs go
berserk yesterday I fell down the stairs
just to see whiskers sitting on my porch
still deciding if I should call someone
about this broken ankle I have now
I love it oh here we go
um
what do we got
um there's just some bangers in there
this is amazing
awesome food and awesome service my wife
won't look me in the eye since I told
her about my secret Bratz dolls
collection I don't know what to do about
it so I'm taking it up with Bloom Cafe
as a last resort
let's kill it
these people are not even from New York
who someone says about durers people
just yeah it's constant
Joe is so moody and complains about
everything even if he gets doesn't get
his daily McDonald's
Bloom Cafe please never allow Joe in
your store he will never give anything
five stars like myself
dude I love DeRosa so much he makes me
so happy really just his energy
his cranky energy just puts a smile on
my face there's something about DeRosa
yeah I think we first started the
podcast a lot of people who knew me and
didn't know him like had to understand
who he was but get you know get used to
a little bit and then they did and now
they love him because they know who he
is he's one of those but when his
grumpiness is likable right yeah when
you first meet him you might be like I
can't get a handle on this guy yeah and
they would be like Trey they were trash
them all done now they're in love with
the guy he has an effect on it Sylvia M
says best muffets on Staten Island my
must visit to pick up your favorite
pastries while dropping off your
complaints for Vera's World infarctions
also [ __ ] you to the best that stole my
Cadillac converter the other day in
front of the house in under three
minutes flat that's sick how many are
awesome still stealing cars
nobody steals cars anymore right
I feel like it's not you don't hear
about it I got my car stolen you
definitely don't hear they still they
stole my radio remember that craze you
used to punch the thing and take the
radio that's so dumb to take a radio now
yeah people don't even know that you
probably don't even know that it was it
was literally an epidemic like you're
trying to flip a radio shine in your car
that says no radio in this car or No
Easy Pass in this car or they invented
because of this a radio that the face
comes off of it or well originally it
was remember the benzi Box yeah my
friend used to pull up and his dad's
like old Buick and like literally pull
the radio out and it looked like a like
a lunch box it needs to walk around with
it yeah so it wouldn't get stolen people
wanted rate crack
crack crack is what it was
no really it was crack is what it was
yeah cause now fentanyl people on
fentanyl are not stealing radials they
don't want to do that a lot of work yeah
fentanyl trying to relax just want to
chill out little Fanny
um
let's see
I'm gonna take it up and then get out
take it I mean you know
man you don't have any energy on
intermittent fasting are you tired it
comes in waves something have some more
whiskey dude sometimes I feel like I
have all the energy in the world and
then sometimes I'm like what am I doing
just eat sometimes I feel like I don't
have a partner
sometimes I feel like my only friend is
the city I live in the City of Angels
something about hey babe together we cry
amen I don't ever wanna feel
like I did head babe take me to the
place I love
take me
I don't ever want to feel
like I did hey babe take me to the place
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe